Hey guys, it's Jan here.
As I said in my review, I was seriously impressed
with Season 2 of Marvel's Daredevil on Netflix.
Not only are there some great new characters
on board this year, but it's also absolutely
jam-packed with shocking, heart-in-your-mouth
moments.
So, I wanted to look back over the most WTF
moments in this video.
Just before I kick off, I've got an awesome
giveaway from our friends at Entertainment
Earth.
For a chance to win this exclusive cool pair
of Marvel collectibles, a Thanos Infinity
Gauntlet Mug and Punisher's Dog Tags, make
sure you subscribe and comment about your
favourite moment in season 2 on this video.
For more details and ways to enter the giveaway,
check out the Gleam link in the video description
below and also the links to the prizes on
Entertainment Earth!
Obviously, spoilers ahead if you haven't watched
the whole of season 2 already!
And if that's you, I've got a non-spoiler
review for you right here.
In the final episode, after battling ninjas,
literally getting pulled through a wall, and
having a heart-to-heart with Matt, Elektra
faces off a barrage of katana-and-longbow-wielding
ninjas on the roof with Daredevil.
During the fight, Nobu hits Daredevil so hard
that he knocks his mask off and is about to
kill him when he ends up stabbing Elektra
instead as she tries to save Daredevil!
'I know now what it feels to be good [...] This
is not the end,' she tells Matt.
And just when we thought the final episode
was over with Matt's reveal of his Daredevil
identity to Karen, the camera cuts to Elektra's
open grave.
And then we see Elektra, who's dressed in
red silk similar to her comic book costume,
being sealed in the Hand's sarcophagus.
I can't wait to see how The Hand resurrect
her for next season!
There's a fantastic fight sequence that makes
good use of confined spaces in episode 12.
But the fight isn't the only reason this sequence
earns its WTF status.
It all starts with a beautiful shot of Daredevil
inching down into the sewers, where he jumps
to the ground in a superhero landing pose
before walking through the tunnel towards
the camera.
It's not until he hears a sword swish, that
he realises he's been surrounded by ninjas;
but he gets disoriented and can't use his
radar sense when they drop their weapons.
And after climbing up a ladder from the tunnels,
he flails about when he's attacked by yet
more ninjas.
That is, until he hears Stick, who's been
captured by the Hand and held nearby.
Stick tells Daredevil to track the ninjas'
breath and as soon as he does that, he wipes
the floor with their ninja asses!
But that's not the end of it!
Daredevil confronts the men torturing Stick,
who takes a bloody piece out of one of his
captors' ears!
Then Elektra arrives to kill Stick for trying
to have her killed!
And Nobu turns up with more ninjas to reveal
that Elektra is actually the mysterious Black
Sky, in other words the Hand's greatest living
weapon!
Daredevil persuades Elektra to reject the
Hand, and instead she puts her signature sai
blades to use helping Stick escape.
Meanwhile Daredevil fights off more ninjas
and kicks Nobu flying over a railing, although
that's not quite enough to put an end to the
ninja with nine lives!
After Daredevil and Punisher's roof-top brawl
in episode 1, which saw Frank Castle bring
a gun to a fist-and-foot fight, it wasn't
long before the two men were at it again.
Episode 2 saw the Man without Fear face off
with Castle once more, only this time, they
had a leaky water tower raining down on them
and a hail of bullets from police who'd set
a trap for Castle.
But ending that battle chained up after falling
through a glass ceiling was just the beginning
of Daredevil's problems.
Yes, after discussing ethics and facing Castle's
moral conundrum, Daredevil had to contend
with a hoard of angry bikers on the rampage
after Castle blew up their bikes.
Let's just say those chains he'd been tied
up in actually came in rather handy as Daredevil
brawled his way through one Dogs of Hell biker
after another down a long corridor and flight
of stairs, kicking, punching, running up walls,
and back-flipping his way out of danger.
This whole sequence was incredibly choreographed,
acted, and shot, from Daredevil's down-and-dirty
brawling mixed with martial arts influences,
to his smashing the ceiling lights with his
chain, to the red light that drenched the
second part of the scene, and Daredevil taking
a moment to stretch his neck before starting
his second ass-kicking session.
Clearly, the intention was to up the ante
from the already amazing corridor fight we
saw in season 1, which was an homage to the
movie Oldboy.
Although Wilson Fisk wasn't in trailers for
Season 2, I had a sneaky suspicion that he'd
be making a comeback this year.
So, I was delighted when he popped up right
at the end of Episode 8 to tell new prison
inmate Frank Castle, 'I see you got my message'.
Such a simple line, yet so loaded with meaning
about the nature and extent of Fisk's power,
even when he's incarcerated.
At that point, he was already running one
of the prison guards and, with Castle's help,
he soon became the new prison kingpin, enjoying
red wine, steak, and a flat-screen TV in his
cell.
I loved Vincent D'Onofrio's nicely understated
turn as the shadowy Fisk in Season 1, and
he certainly brought the brilliance again
this season, making sure we knew that, with
Fisk, danger is ever-present, no matter how
softly spoken or cultured he appears.
During the exchange between Fisk and fellow
prisoner Dutton, who lays down the law, in
episode 9, you just knew Dutton was already
living on borrowed time.
And what about when Matt Murdoch goes to see
Fisk in prison to confront him about Frank
Castle's escape?
Fisk goes from restrained to caged beast in
a matter of minutes when Murdoch threatens
to make sure Fisk never sees his beloved Vanessa
again.
Frank Castle didn't realise quite what he
was getting himself in to with Fisk when he
agreed to off the prison big-shot Dutton,
who facilitated the Central Park deal between
the Dogs of Hell, Irish Mob, and Mexican Cartel
during which Castle's family was wiped out.
After taking out Dutton's right-hand man,
Castle puts his shiv to use dragging the truth
out of Dutton about what went down that fateful
day, including details about the involvement
of undercover cops and the Blacksmith, a shadowy
new player in the drug trade.
But it's what happens after this that makes
this scene a true WTF moment.
When Castle tries to exit Dutton's cell block
after killing him, the prison guards on Fisk's
payroll won't let him out; instead, they open
the cell doors so Dutton's men can kill Castle!
Cue Castle slashing, stabbing, stamping, and
pummelling his way through a pack of enraged
and armed prisoners until he's the last man
standing and his face, arms, and white prison
uniform are soaked in blood.
It's an especially savage scene which showcases
Castle's brutal, no-holds-barred fighting
style to great effect.
And, of course, it all happens in a narrow
corridor, something that's fast becoming a
signature of the show's action scenes.
Of course, there were loads of other crazy
moments this season too, including the Irish
mob boss Finn stabbing one of his associates
in the eye and torturing Castle, the creepy
children being tapped for their blood, the
big ninja fight at the hospital, the sequence
at the Yakatomi building, and tons more!
Now, what are the moments that shocked you
most in Season 2 of Daredevil?
Tell me know in the comments below!
And don't forget to subscribe and leave a
comment about your favourite Season 2 moment
on this video for a chance to win this awesome
pair of exclusive Marvel collectibles from
our friends at Entertainment Earth!
For more details and ways to enter the comp,
plus links to what you can win, check out
the Gleam link in the video description below!
If you liked this video, I've got loads more
comic book movie and TV videos for both Marvel
and DC!
Check out the playlists here and do subscribe!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, superhero lovers!